es hora de que pasemos a un
entendimiento más profundo de la meiosis
y para eso vamos a empezar con las
células criminales es quién voy a
dibujar por aquí una célula germinal
déjame ponerla por aquí como ya
mencionamos una célula germinal es
aquella célula déjame dibujar de justo
por aquí la cual puede entrar en mitosis
para producir otras células germinales o
bien puede entrar en meiosis para
producir gametos entonces esta de aquí
es una célula germinal esta de aquí y
bueno déjenme dibujar por aquí también
su núcleo y éste lo voy a hacer bastante
grande porque ahora vamos a hablar sobre
cromosomas y por lo tanto quiero que los
visualices bien también voy a dibujar
por aquí un centrosoma este por aquí es
uno de mini centrosomas lo voy a hacer
justo por aquí el cual después jugará un
papel bastante importante
este de color azul y cada centrosoma
tiene dos en triodos en él es importante
que te vayas acostumbrando a la
terminología y en los vídeos de mitosis
me enfoqué en las células de un
organismo que tenían un número diploide
de dos es decir que tenían un par
homólogo que tenían un cromosoma por
cada uno de sus padres en este vídeo no
me voy a enfocar en el ser humano que
tiene 23 pares o 46 cromosomas me voy a
enfocar en una especie no sé en esta que
me voy a tomar con un número de play de
más sencillo con un número diploide
igual a 4 entonces tenemos por aquí dos
cromosomas del padre este va a ser uno
de los cromosomas del padre y date
cuenta que los estoy dibujando en el
estado de cromatina es decir están
bastante desarrollados aquí podemos
tener un cromosoma largo y después se me
ocurre tener por aquí aunque mucho más
pequeño y bueno también para la madre la
madre también tiene
dos cromosomas homólogos este va a ser
el de la madre lo voy a poner justo por
aquí y otro pequeño otro corto que
proviene de la madre aquí están
obviamente esto es una inmensa
simplificación pero espero que con esto
se pueda comunicar la idea entonces esta
célula tiene un número diploide de
cromosomas déjenme notar de aquí tiene
un número diploide
d
de cromosomas y bueno este número
diploide es igual a 4 estás de acuerdo
tenemos cuatro de ellos y esta de aquí
quedamos que era una célula germinal de
lugo
no está de más anotarlo y bueno esta
célula germinal entrará a la interfase
dejarlo ponerlos y va a entrar a la
interfase y
fase en donde va a crecer y replicar su
adn y su centrosoma y para ello lo voy a
dibujar justo aquí quiero usar el
espacio cuidadosamente para que veas lo
que le va a pasar porque va a haber
muchos pasos después de esto déjame
agarrar este color con este color voy a
dibujar de nuevo a mi celular la voy a
dibujar por acá aquí está mi celular muy
bien y bueno voy a poner también su
núcleo su núcleo lo voy a pintar de este
color y ahora date cuenta de lo
siguiente lo que va a pasar es justo lo
siguiente cada uno de estos cromosomas
se va a duplicar el adn se va a replicar
entonces este cromosoma largo del padre
ahora lo tenemos justo por aquí lo voy a
poner justo por aquí pero como todo el
adn se replicó entonces ahora se verá
algo así voy a tener por aquí el mismo
cromosoma del padre y como podemos ver
este va a estar unido a un centro pero
aquí está su centro mero y yo
y seguro que estás pensando que hay
muchas palabras con centro pero bueno lo
importante es que te des cuenta que lo
estoy dibujando todavía en su estado de
cromatina de hecho está todo extendido
no es tan compactados por lo que no
podrías ver de una manera clara estás x
en un microscopio simple entonces solo
se replicó y ojo después de replicarse
sigue siendo un cromosoma tiene el doble
de material genético pero sigue siendo
solo un cromosoma este cromosoma que
tengo aquí ahora bien está hecho por dos
cromáticas hermanas hablamos mucho de
esto en el vídeo de mitosis recuerdas
pero no hace daño reforzarlo porque
después se puede volver un poco confuso
y bueno también vamos a tener este
pequeño del padre pero él también se va
a replicar así que lo voy a poner justo
por aquí y aquí tenemos nuestro centro
pero lo voy a poner justo por aquí date
cuenta que se forman dos cromáticas
hermanas estos dos siguen siendo los dos
cromosomas del padre pero
ahora tienen el doble de adn
contienen la misma información solamente
que ahora hay versiones duplicadas de
esa misma información y lo mismo sucede
con los cromosomas provenientes de la
madre así que los voy a dibujar por aquí
por aquí tengo uno de los cromosomas
provenientes de la madre y bueno voy a
dibujar por aquí el otro de ellos y les
voy a poner su centro pero va a estar
justo por aquí este cromosoma es un
monólogo a este observa que también se
replican por lo que habrá dos cromáticas
hermanas y luego habrá otra pequeña
hebra proveniente de la madre la voy a
dibujar por aquí y bueno por acá va a
estar la otra y también voy a dibujar su
centro pero justo por aquí estas
homóloga a la que proviene del padre y
bueno también se replicará justo así al
final de la interfase todo esto estará
expandido en esta fase no estarán con la
forma de las x claramente visibles las
dibuje de esta manera porque si no
tendrías bastantes problemas para ver
cómo se replica y al final de todo esto
también tendremos que el centrosoma
también se duplicó así que lo voy a
dibujar por aquí
centrosoma y otro por aquí otro por aquí
y ahora ya estamos listos de hecho ya
estamos listos ya sea para la mitosis o
para la meiosis pero como dije en este
vídeo nos enfocaremos en la meiosis
entonces hagamos meiosis y para eso
hablaremos de las primeras fases a las
cuales llamamos meiosis 1 así que para
eso déjame ver lo que va a pasar en la
profa c 1 la fase inicial de la meiosis
1 es la profa se 1 así que veamos qué
pasa en esta propia se uno y para eso lo
primero que voy a dibujar es esta célula
la voy a poner justo por aquí algo más o
menos así y bueno en la profa se uno lo
que van a suceder es un par de cosas la
primera es que la membrana nuclear
empieza a disolverse así que la voy a
poner justo así y algo muy parecido
habíamos visto en la profa se de la
mitosis recuerdas entonces la membrana
nuclear empieza
a disolverse a estos de aquí los
centrosomas lo que va a pasar con ellos
es que se van a separar uno se va a ir
hasta acá y el otro se va a ir hasta acá
hasta el otro extremo y después lo que
vamos a ver acá dentro es lo siguiente
el adn comienza a compactarse por lo
tanto ahora sí puedo dibujarlos como se
debe
voy a dibujar aquí al adn del padre lo
voy a dibujar justo por aquí así y así
algo así entonces este es el cromosoma
que proviene del padre y bueno ahora voy
a dibujar el que proviene de la madre
que se va a ver más o menos así y los
estoy sobreponiendo a propósito porque
ahorita vamos a hablar de que también se
pueden poner sobre puestos así que lo
voy a poner justo por acá por aquí tengo
también de la madre y me faltan los dos
centro - que los voy a dibujar ahora con
color azul uno por aquí y el otro por
acá ahora vamos con los cortos y los
cortos se van a ver más o menos así voy
a dibujar el del padre por aquí
bueno no espera espera de hecho los voy
a poner en la dos contrarios solo para
mostrar que no necesariamente los
cromosomas del padre siempre están del
lado izquierdo así que los voy a poner
por acá aquí tengo a uno y el otro lo
voy a poner justo por acá no lo voy a
poner sobre puestos para que veas que
también puede ser que no estén sobre
puestos aquí están justo el otro el de
la madre y voy a poner sus respectivos
centros con color azul con color azul
para que resalte y de nuevo cada uno de
estos es un par homólogo este es un paro
homólogo este otro también es un par
homólogo y ahora el adn fue replicado en
cada uno de los cromosomas del par
homólogo tienes dos cromáticas hermanas
por lo que en este par homólogo tienes
cuatro cromáticas y déjame atraparlo
porque estas cuatro cromáticas reciben
un nombre especial a esto se le conoce
con el nombre de t
así que lo voy a poner aquí esta es una
de otra
ahora la razón por la cual dibuje a
estos superpuestos es que cuando estamos
en la fase 1 de la media o si uno de
hammett y qatar esto de aquí estoy
hablando de la profa se pro fa
y uno justo aquí es que puede suceder
una recombinación genética una
recombinación homóloga una vez más esto
es un par homólogo un cromosoma que se
obtuvo del padre el organismo lo obtuvo
por una célula de su padre y el otro
cromosoma proviene de la madre y como
son homólogos pueden tener distintos
pares de bases diferente adn pero tienen
los mismos genes y esto puede ser una
sobre simplificación pero imagínate
aunque el mismo lugar en cada uno de
ellos puede codificar para no ser para
el color de ojos o no sé para qué tan
alto eres o para la personalidad aunque
nada es tan simple en el adn pero esto
es sólo para darte una idea de cómo es
este proceso y ahora bien la razón de
por qué los super puse de esta manera es
para mostrar cómo es la recombinación
puede suceder es más se me ocurre que
puedo hacer un acercamiento y ponerte
aquí aquí al cromosoma del pan
lo voy a hacer justo por acá este va a
ser uno de los cromosomas del padre algo
más o menos por acá voy a poner justo
por acá a la otra cromática de este pero
mucho más del padre algo así así está
perfecto y después voy a poner aquí con
color azul su centro pero ojo no te
vayas a confundir con los centrosomas
que son estos de aquí una vez más este
está en su forma condensada
este es un cromosoma hecho de dos
cromáticas hermanas y bueno también voy
a dibujar al de la madre el cromosoma
homólogo proveniente de la madre anne va
a ser este de aquí déjame ponerlo por
aquí voy a poner aquí al cromosoma
homólogo a que proviene de la madre y lo
voy a poner también por aquí así que
aquí tienes al otro al otro cromosoma y
por cierto también voy a poner aquí su
centro mero justo por aquí entonces este
es el cromosoma homólogo de la madre y
la recombinación puede ocurrir justo
aquí es decir
esta parte que tengo aquí y si te das
cuenta lo que va a pasar
déjame ver es que ahora el dibujo se va
a ver más o menos así después de que
sucede la recombinación una manera de
pensar lo es que esencialmente las
cromáticas se rompen e intercambian
estas pequeñas secciones entonces por
aquí va a estar el cromosoma del padre
déjame dibujarlo algo más o menos así
por acá también lo voy a dibujar lo voy
a dibujar más o menos así este va a ser
el cromosoma del padre más o menos se va
a ver así y ahora esta parte que tengo
aquí donde se hizo la recombinación esta
sección va a codificar ahora para los
genes similares pero ahora la cromatina
contiene la información genética de la
madre así que se va a ver más o menos
algo así y va a pasar algo similar para
la madre vamos a tener aquí a uno de los
cromosomas déjame dibujarlo más o menos
así aquí tengo a una de las cromáticas
de este cromosoma por aquí tengo a la
otra cromática de este cromo
justo es esta de aquí pero ahora esta
parte que tengo aquí va a contener la
información genética del padre va a
haber una recombinación justo aquí y no
olvidemos los centro menos tengo un
centro mero aquí y otro centro pero aquí
y es que esto es realmente interesante
la recombinación puede suceder en
cualquier momento y en varias ocasiones
y puede llevar a cosas no óptimas a
códigos sin sentido es decir puede
llevar a un organismo no funcional pero
esto puede suceder comúnmente durante la
meiosis y esta es una manera de obtener
más variación anteriormente ya hemos
hablado de la reproducción sexual y la
reproducción sexual es la que introduce
la variación en una población y
obviamente cuando distintos
espermatozoides se encuentran distintos
óvulos esto introduce una variación pero
incluso en los pares homólogos puede
haber un intercambio de secciones de adn
y esto es interesante porque como
mencionamos estos cromosomas tienen
y numerosos genes y un gen es un tipo de
código para una proteína o un conjunto
de proteínas y lo que voy a decir será
una sobre simplificación pero lo mejor
en esta sección de aquí esté codificada
para el color de ojos se me ocurre justo
por aquí y algo relacionado a esto puede
hacer esta parte del padre que tengo
justo aquí y entonces cuando se hace la
recombinación lo que va a suceder es que
esta otra sección obtenida por la madre
va a tener ahora aquí el alelo del color
de los ojos mientras que ahora esta
sección del padre tiene el alelo del
color de ojos e imagínate puede ser que
tu mamá te llevaría a tener ojos claros
mientras que tu papá te llevaría a tener
ojos oscuros y ahora que tu papá te va a
dar el alelo de los ojos claros mientras
que tu mamá te daría el alelo de los
ojos obscuros codifica para distintas
variaciones de ese gen y una vez más
muchas personas se confunden entre genes
cromosomas y todo eso
uno de estos cromosomas de estos
cromosomas contiene varios genes los
cromosomas son unas moléculas muy largas
de adn que codifica para un gran número
de genes distintos y un gen es una
pequeña sección del cromosoma que puede
codificar para una proteína en
particular entonces todo esto es lo que
sucede en la pro fase 1 en la profa se
uno tienes esta condensación de los
cromosomas de estos pares homólogos y
puedes tener esta recombinación esta que
acabamos de ver justo aquí y es muy
interesante porque la recombinación no
tiende a pasar en puntos aleatorios que
puedan romper la información genética
tiende a suceder en puntos bastante
precisos y los lugares donde sucede este
rompimiento los lugares donde pasan
justo esto de aquí se le conoce con el
nombre de que asma y si hablas en plural
que asma está suena como si fuera el
título de una película de terror pero
bueno vamos a poner el nombre y asma
aquí
y el hecho de que sucedan en puntos muy
precisos es parte de la belleza del
universo o al menos de la biología de
cómo a través de billones de años de
evolución este tipo de cosas se ha
optimizado para tener mayor variación y
para que todo esto suceda de maneras muy
precisas voy a dejar por aquí este vídeo
sólo llega a la profa se uno pero esta
es una idea muy importante esta es la
idea de recombinación entre los
homólogos y de este entrecruzamiento de
los cromosomas que vimos aquí y a partir
de aquí podemos continuar con el resto
de la meiosis 1 y luego con la meiosis 2